well that did not last long Elon Musk  takes over Twitter puts Kanye West back  on Twitter Kanye West almost immediately  gets banned from Twitter for being for  inciting violence and listen I don't  have the answer here I I would uh I  don't know what I would do if I was in  charge of Twitter or any of these  platforms where the line of free speech  is versus doing more harm with things  like concern violence for me my take on  this is I just try to put up my  positivity like if you're upset about  the negativity and and the vitriol on  the system and just people raging on  each other the best thing you can do is  put out more positivity people organize  for hate and they organize for violence  and I love to help organize for kindness  and for positivity and so if you're  struggling to make sense of this and you  think it's all lost it's not you can  make a difference by putting out more  positive content belief